hey Vsauce Michael here with a video
inspired by orange pumpkin seven who
asked me to cover cool screen savers now
at first I was like screen savers modern
monitors don't even need them but then I
sleuth two-round and realized what a
great idea it was there's some amazing
stuff out there and thought further ado
let's get started first sound stream
this screensaver uses your computer's
microphone and three spawns two noises
meet lotsa Ishar zooms in on infinite
illusion drawings the zoom never stops
but stare at it for a while and then
look at a wall or look at your hand
pretty trippy let's move on to something
more utilitarian like clocks word clock
ticks words every second that when read
together tell you the time you can also
choose the more familiar analog clock
Uniqlo is a clothing label that offers a
free screensaver clock that sometimes
turns into this
sette at home as a screensaver that
connects your computer through the
internet to a database of data collected
from the sky your computer and other
computers using the screensaver evaluate
that data looking for patterns and signs
of extraterrestrial life along the same
lines is electric sheep when it begins
your computer communicates with other
computers running the same screensaver
and together all the idle computers pull
their processing power to produce and
render fractal images into impact movies
so what you're looking at is in a way a
bunch of computers collective dream if
you prefer evil computers make it look
like how from 2001 a Space Odyssey and
even if people don't get the reference
they'll at least think you're just doing
super smartypants genius stuff breve
Walker is incredible
it makes creatures out of randomly
generated shapes with randomly assigned
movements the distance a creature can
move is measured and after the first 25
genetic algorithm selects the top movers
and makes them together to form combo
children shapes just like human
reproduction then the new generation is
tested and among those the best
performers are combined three below is a
screensaver that continuously drops
Legos to make cool shapes and while it's
up you can use the arrow keys to
position the pieces yourself I leave you
with some water lots of water turns your
screen into a puddle and rainy day too
soaks your screen like paper so that the
color and ink run so there you go that
was a dozen screen savers I thought were
cool enough I had to share them big
thanks to orange pumpkin 7 for the idea
and if you're a geek and you're looking
for tips and tricks on interviewing for
awesome geek jobs in technology fields
you should check out what my friends are
doing with dice comm where they
interview people with awesome tech jobs
about tips and tricks about interview
you can even answer interview sample
questions for a chance to win a Kinect
so hey what are you waiting for go try
it out and as always thanks for watching
Oh